advice from George Lucas on finding your
passion as seen in zuga 101 find your
passion
my first six years in the business were
hopeless there are a lot of times when
you sit and say why am I doing this I'll
never make it it's just not gonna happen
I should go out and get a real job and
try to survive you have to find
something that you love enough to be
able to take risks jump over hurdles and
break through the brick walls that are
going to be placed in front of you
otherwise you'll stop with the first
giant hurdle once I started in that
department USC film school I found what
it was that I loved and was good at and
I realized I could do it very well and
that I enjoyed doing it it really
ignited a passion in me and it took off
from there I'm extremely grateful that I
discovered my passion I love movies I
love to watch them I love to make them
it's hard work making movies if you
don't really love it then it ain't worth
it it's just a matter of moving around
until you've discovered what it is to
learn more check out zuga 101 find your
passion by clicking the link below